check out joe musgrove in his fifth
start and this is his second start back
since coming off the injured list
i'll tip the strikeout
nicely done here's a 1-2
swing and a miss struck him out now that
curveball now he's placing it he's got
back-to-back strikeouts let's take a
look at dylan cson for his ninth start
looking for his sixth win era a touch
above three and a quarter
another 3-2 pitch and that's on the
ground to the right side backhanded
nicely there by embraer he'll feed cease
to the bag in time and one two three go
the pirates
to the left
with a late start frazier with a great
diving catch
made up for it well done
end up catching that ball it looked like
it was falling quickly very nice head
first dive getting it about maybe a foot
off the ground
oh nice play there's one but they won't
get to a pretty play by newman to
gonzalez i mean it was a perfect perfect
flip
oh off of musgrove scrambles to try and
get it out and now we'll find out how
he's how he's feeling oh my that's he
made it look like i could hit the shoe i
hit him off the calf ouch
swinging a miss strike three he didn't
know what to do with that puppy is it
kept sailing and salem and two down
pitchers duel so far tonight no score as
we begin the fourth here's the o2
swinging a miss struck him out a nice
breaking ball down and away he picked
him apart
oh wow
back-to-back strikeouts
3-2 pitch
got him
so he strikes out the side
foul tip held by granddaughte that is
strike three just a second strikeout so
far here for dylan cease working here to
reynolds and the pitch on the way and a
grounder to the right side that'll be
fielded by madrigal he'll throw to first
and abrillo will kick the cushion there
with his right foot and the inning has
come to an end one two three go to the
pirates here in the fourth one out
double here's tim anderson he doubled to
start the game
and lined into center
runner's gonna be held at third he's
gonna go right through the stop sign
madrigal is going to be out at home
plate get a closer view of it here
stallings reaching back
and
boy that's close
close enough that they will challenge
well done again another assist from
brian reynolds connor with an infield
single that off the pitcher musk grove
right hand side eats up newman at second
base here comes tim from third and he is
safe this time
that's just flat out great base running
by tim anderson because he never took
anything for granted now here is yasmani
garanda with moncada at first and
nevarowski is the 1-1 and a high fly
ball and a deep right field
watching this one sail out of here is
the right fielder polanco it's a two-run
shot
the only question
was would it splash down and it's a
two-run home run for us monty grand doll
and it's three nothing socks keep ryan
hayes bounced sharply to short
line toward right
and back toward the wall and off the
wall
over mazzara's head and so key brian
hayes goes to third standing up with a
triple
it's three to one now kevin newman
here's the 01. swinging a ground ball
right up third baseline fairball from
deep in foul ground moncada throws late
onto first hayes is in it's an rbi
infield hit for kevin newman the pirates
get two back three to two now they trail
who's gonna play on it
oh what a play indeed by abreu also
there but it was abreu who made the
catch and they are going to give
fraser second base saying that he went
well
we i guess he would have gone out of
play
he did it almost playfully to because
madrigal is
a diminutive what five eight we said
compared to the big
first baseman
the ground ta and shortstop and that
will do it for round number three
socks survived
now eloy
saw him chopping at his hand he does
swing away right hand side and this
one's ticketed for the wall off the wall
it goes abreu gets to third he's getting
waved around jose another play at the
plate he is saved
that's why you give him the 3-0 green
light and that's why jose was off to the
races so the catcher jacob stallings
down to the plate
liner out to right down base hit
heading toward the corner and he'll kick
off the sidewall zara has to charge it
newman is in and stalling's in at second
base he doubles
back-to-back doubles for the pirates
here in the eighth inning it's four to
three gonzalez at the plate
chopped over the head of the drawn and
infielder and this game is tied up
gonzalez extends his hitting streak to
nine straight and the pirates scored
twice in the eighth to tie it at four
it's colin moran with two outs gonzalez
at third a tie game in the eight three
two
on the ground right hand side jose's got
it and the socks will go to the ninth in
a tie ball game
gonzales gonna throw to third how about
that oh my god wow you don't see that
very often
gonzo to keep brian hayes
score they win it and now
he brian hayes will be coming up
gets away that's a beautiful thing
and that run 90 feet away
mister walk off kevin newman
a little tapper martin headed to the
plate
and
he dropped the ball the buck goes with
it raise the jolly roger
grondol dropped the ball
we'll go ahead and give him the walk off
again
5-4 the pirates come back for a second
straight game